hopes are high that the 13th installment
of the popular slasher franchise will
make it to the big screen sooner rather
than later
until then let's take a look back at all
the Jason Voorhees stories that never
came to life these are the Friday the
13th projects you'll never get to see a
crossover between a Nightmare on Elm
Street and Friday the 13th was first
pitched in 1987 and while it took 16
years for Freddy vs. Jason to become a
reality
loads of scripts were written to support
a slew of potential mashup ideas
[Music]
according to Bloody Disgusting a
potential script called nightmare 13
Freddy meets Jason wrapped jason
voorhees 'as original story right into
Freddy's suggesting Freddy Krueger was
the Camp Crystal Lake counselor who
drowned Jason Voorhees this angle gave
Jason an intriguing motive for becoming
a killer and wanting to battle Freddy
the script was reportedly rewritten to
include a battle scene between Freddy
and Jason that took place in a boxing
ring in hell an actor would portray Ted
Bundy is the ring announcer and guess
who was supposed to sit right in the
front row Adolf Hitler perhaps it's for
the best that we never got to see this
one New Line Cinema pitched their own
Freddy vs. Jason idea in 1997 and the OJ
Simpson trial inspired their version of
the story according to flickering men
the script took a similar approach to
Wes Craven's new nightmare adding a
metal layer that explored Jason going on
trial for his many murders are you
trying to justify to me the fact that
you're an idiot Freddy Krueger
eventually enters the action and
attempts to use Jason to get out of
dreamland and into the real world well
it certainly would have been interesting
to watch Jason take the stand much like
Freddy did in an episode of Freddy's
nightmares called no more mr. nice guy
directed by tobe Hooper after the
success of Platinum Dunes Friday the
13th reboot in 2009 paramount and Warner
Brothers started working on a follow-up
with the studio are you looking for this
because it it completes your outfit
Bloody Disgusting reports a sequel
called Friday the 13th Camp blood was
written in 2010 by Damien Shannon and
Mark Swift the same guys who wrote the
Freddy vs. Jason script according to
multiple rumors Derek Mears was going to
play Jason again the film would be shot
in 3d and the plan was to release the
film opposite Platinum Dunes other genre
reboots 2010's a Nightmare on Elm Street
producer Brad fuller ultimately
announced the cancellation of the
project on Twitter in 2010 writing it's
not my call I would drop everything and
make it today if they wanted it seven
years later a never-before-seen image
was revealed on Shannon and Swift's
Twitter feed the title page of their
never filmed script looks like they were
planning to kill off Jason once and for
all
yeah right we weren't donating we were
just wretches in 2013 Christopher
Nolan's interstellar managed to reignite
Friday the 13th hopes according to The
Hollywood Reporter Warner Brothers gave
its rights to the franchise over to
Paramount to have a stake in a science
fiction epic David Bruckner the director
of the Amateur Night installment of the
2012 for anthology film VHS was brought
on to direct Nick and Tosca the
screenwriter behind the Hannibal film
adaptation signed on to write the script
what they came up with sounds like it
would have been a lot of fun it would
take place in the 80s Jason's mom would
have a role in the film and it would
allegedly focus on Jason's supernatural
mythology Bruckner told Fangoria he
wanted to make a cross between slasher
horror and slacker comedy my take on it
was that I wanted to do Dazed and
Confused meets Jason Voorhees a genuine
last day of school coming-of-age story
unfortunately due to the poor box office
returns of the horror sequel rings
paramount wound up slashing Friday the
13th right off its lineup
with the story of Jason Voorhees work on
television the CW's Mark Pedowitz
clearly thought the answer was yes
in 2015 the network announced they had a
Friday the 13th TV series in the works
series creator Stephen long Mitchell
described the tone as quote a cross
between the first season of true
detective and Twin Peaks on acid
that's an odd analogy considering those
shows seem like they're on acid already
[Music]
according to Mitchell the story would
have followed a police detective looking
for his lost brother in Crystal Lake the
central mystery would revolve around
whether Jason was killing again or a
copycat was on the loose sadly the CW
ended up passing on the series Pedowitz
told Collider we didn't believe it was a
sustainable script or a sustainable
series it was a very good pilot but not
a sustainable series
[Music]